speaking of that spirit in science
that's why I was so glad to see both of
you at this panel that Governor DeSantis
convened a couple months ago and Brett I
want to play a clip this is a portion of
you on that panel the message that was
given to us by public health authorities
was not just inept it actually went well
beyond that it was really the inverse of
everything we should have done and
because it was
forced on us with this strong form of
coercion
it it was widely accepted because people
didn't have a choice but what we don't
often talk about we do talk now about
the the Adverse Events for example of
these so-called vaccines but what we
don't talk about is the question of what
would have happened if we had taken a
different path
so Brett what would have happened if we
had taken another path I could probably
be convinced that if we had done
absolutely nothing things would have
been much better now when we see all the
psychological problems that young people
are having it having all of the
depression the the collapse in the
education system you know literally
five-year-olds who are having delayed
speech now because of masks I mean the
litany and the list goes on and on
well I in my mind there's no question
that if we had done nothing we would
have ended up being better off because
what doing nothing would involve is
clinicians figuring out what worked in
their offices and talking over the
internet and at the water cooler we
would have developed protocols for
dealing with covet and the fact is it's
actually a very tractable disease if
we'd really done nothing including not
doing the gain of function research we
probably wouldn't have had a pandemic in
the first place almost certainly
so there's no question that doing
nothing was superior to the uh massive
self-inflicted wounds that we created
with our uh our Beyond inept
response as to Jay's point I don't
disagree with you Jay about the fact
that we can get back to a proper
scientific culture but where you and I
might disagree is I can't see us doing
it in less than a generation
because let you know first of all we've
trained all of the people whose staff
our medical institutes and the academy
and the journals and the governmental
regulatory apparatus we've we've trained
all of these people in Conformity we've
punished them for standing up we've
fired them for doing it and you can't
just simply say to them oh those days
are over now be honest they don't
remember how they don't know how to do
the job and so if you were going to fix
the system
you have to train a new generation that
hasn't learned that lesson and then the
bitter pill is this who's going to train
them
what do you think about that Jay I think
it might work at the state level right I
mean that's why DeSantis convened you
guys right how do how do we as
Floridians you know he was saying how do
I as the governor make sure that the
federal government is not going to do
this again I mean do you think it just
has to be sort of a bottom-up micro
level that will work something like that
I mean I I think I think I hear I hear
you Brett I mean I hear I hear the uh uh
the frustration but I I mean I've met so
many excellent young people as
scientists who who are we you know I
mean I'm biased about the ones I've
trained but even the ones I haven't
trained
um and I I think that that spirit's
there it's innate it's just suppressed
by structures that make it so that you
you you you move forward by by not being
an excellent scientist necessarily but
by like playing the bureaucratic game
better
I think uh and this is my this is Maybe
This Is The Economist in me like if you
change the structures and the incentives
I really strongly believe that it won't
be the same people like the people that
are that are good at bureaucratic
infighting you know Tony facci is a good
example of this won't necessarily rise
anymore
um it'll be very difficult but I think a
lot of people enter size especially a
lot of young people understand because
they want to know they want this is an
incredible beautiful process for
learning true things about the way that
the Universe works right that's why we
under science because it's it's just
beautiful
um and uh a lot of people are still in
science like that Brett I think and I
don't believe that we have to retrain
them I think we just have to give them
the right incentives and then they'll do
the right thing
um at least some of them